Joshua Rob gentlemen congratulations
your hard work has paid off and you're
both moving forward into the final round
of the supersize competition you
probably noticed that throughout this
competition we had a little bit of a
theme
there were two giant Springs we had two
ice blocks and there were two punching
bags
and we're gonna keep that theme of twos
going you guys will have four days to
build these
a pair of elephant fighting swords
awesome
the double elephant fighting swords or
dab nagao traced their Origins back to
18th century lamina Kingdom in modern
day Thailand used by mounted elephant
Warriors these massive heavy blades
featured a long handle to assist in
counterbalance both blades measure
around 30 inches and feature a flame
back spine and upswept tip these swords
were designed not only to attack other
mounted Soldiers with lethal stabs and
slashes but the ridges and Peaks along
the spine had the ability to trap an
adversary's blade today these swords are
still used in traditional time martial
arts
this is the largest pair of weapons we
have ever asked Miss to go home and make
so good luck we will see you both in
four days
my name is Josh Meyer I'm 47 years old
from Flagstaff Arizona and Emma Smith
for about five years my biggest strength
to smithing is probably the variety of
things I do because I'm not just a
blades Smith I'm a full-time artist I
work primarily in the mediums of stone
steel and wood I've decided I want to
make Damascus for these blades
only got one Forge so I want to get both
of those billets in there if I can so I
can rotate the billets back and forth
and keep this process going along so far
looking good so grinding these three
Flames into the top of these blades is
pretty tricky and I can't mess this up
because this is attached to this entire
swords I want to make sure that these
Flames look really nice because every
little detail counts and if Robin does
better than me or if I grind one too
short I could really mess myself up I
like it so I've got the profile shaped
out I've got the Flames all nice so now
it's time for me to get this thing heat
treated because my time is ticking
oh yeah straight as an arrow wow so now
it's time to do the glue up I've got so
many holes I'm really concerned about
making sure that all the pins fit in
there and everything hooks up together
nicely yeah okay saved it now I've got
to hurry up I named my swords chaos and
Tranquility just because I use two
different types of Walnut and it was
sort of a yin and the Yang feel for me
all glued up Rob I hope you did well
buddy because it's game time
oh
my name is Rob Harvey I'm from Charlotte
North Carolina I work for the Department
of Veterans Affairs and I'm a part-time
bladesmith I was in the Marine Corps and
I actually spent most of my time in
Okinawa Japan I definitely take
influence from the Japanese style of
bladesmithing I had a great respect for
visiting their shops in Japan my goal is
to make 150 layer Damascus Billet I'm
going to forge out both blades and
hopefully get them heat treated get in
there I've never done anything this big
but I'm moving pretty quickly very
efficiently so I can start building up
my heat treating oven unfortunately I'm
going to have to modify this a little
bit to get the swords in here but gonna
have to do because of the size of these
blades being able to heat these blades
up evenly is very challenging
there's one
there's two there were no cracks warps
nothing crazy like that but my biggest
concern throughout the entire home Forge
challenge was my heat treating you know
my heat treating oven was not up to par
for handling that type of heat treatment
I really just hope that they're strong
enough
nice and smooth at first I was a little
worried about what I had to do with the
super size challenge but ultimately I
feel really good about it they feel good
in the hand I met all the parameters
both my swords are light and fast and
they're sharp
placements welcome to the kill test
Rob you're first ready for this
absolutely let's do it at First Sight
these tests are definitely terrifying
because I know that my blades had some
struggles in the Heat Treating area I'm
so nervous
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
a big old Bend in it they both do wow
all right Rob let's talk about your
elephant fighting swords here first up
that Damascus patterns you have here are
stunning but
we have a problem and during the test
both blades took a very significant Bend
as you can see here they are kind of
offset they're not centered and judging
by how extreme these are it looks like
there's a major heat treat issue with
both ear blades with every strike they
will continue to bend more and more so
unfortunately I would not feel safe
testing them further
now Rob both of your blades did make it
through our kill test but in the midst
of that test they both took very serious
bends down near the handle our judges
did decide to issue a vote of no
confidence and we cannot continue
testing your blades but you're not out
of the fight yet Joshua in order to take
home the title of Fortune fire champion
and get a check to 10 grand your blades
will have to make it through our kill
test with no disqualifying issues are
you ready I am so ready let's do this
foreign
foreign
Joshua song about your elephant swords
here these blades are nicely done I
don't see any damage to your blades are
nice and tight and straight overall your
weapons
will Keel thank you
well Joshua congratulations your blades
made it through the kill test completely
unscathed now Rob we want to say thank
you for coming out and trying so hard in
this competition but your time on the
forge has ended I'm gonna have to ask
you to please step off the forge floor
thank you thank you well Joshua you are
the new Fortune fire Champion you're
going to be shooting a check for ten
thousand dollars congratulations thank
you so much guys
feels amazing it's very surreal I can't
believe it you got plans for money kind
of going back to my shop right on this
was a huge personal Journey for me but
as a full-time bladesmith an artist in a
push my creativity Ingenuity and it was
incredible I'm Joshua Meyer and I'm the
forge and fire champion